[Music]
how high can you count on your fingers
it seems like a question with an obvious
answer after all most of us have 10
fingers or to be more precise 8 fingers
and 2 thumbs this gives us a total of 10
digits on our two hands which we use to
count to 10 it's no coincidence that the
10 symbols we use in our modern
numbering system are called digits as
well but that's not the only way to
count in some places it's customary to
go up to 12 on just one hand how well
each finger is divided into three
sections and we have a natural pointer
to indicate each one the thumb that
gives us an easy way to count to 12 on
one hand and if we want to count higher
we can use the digits on our other hand
to keep track of each time we get to 12
up to 5 groups of 12 or 60 better yet
let's use the sections on the second
hand to count 12 groups of 12 up to 144
that's a pretty big improvement but we
can go higher by finding more countable
parts on each hand for example each
finger has three sections and three
creases for a total of six things to
count now we're up to 24 on each hand
and using our other hand to mark groups
of 24 gets us all the way to 576 can we
go any higher it looks like we've
reached the limit of how many different
finger parts we can count with any
precision so let's think of something
different one of our greatest
mathematical inventions is the system of
positional notation where the placement
of symbols allows for different
magnitudes of value as in the number 999
even though the same symbol is used
three times each position indicates a
different order of magnitude so we can
use positional value on our fingers to
beat our previous record let's forget
about finger sections for a moment and
look at the simplest case of having just
two options per finger up and down this
won't allow us to represent powers of
ten but it's perfect for the counting
system that uses power
of two otherwise known as binary in
binary each position has double the
value of the previous one so we can
assign our fingers values of one two
four eight all the way up to 512 and any
positive integer up to a certain limit
can be expressed as a sum of these
numbers for example the number 7 is 4
plus 2 plus 1 so we can represent it by
having just these three fingers raised
meanwhile 250 is 128 plus 64 plus 32
plus 16 plus 8 plus 2 how high can we go
now that would be the number with all 10
fingers raised or 1023 is it possible to
go even higher it depends on how
dexterous you feel if you can bend each
finger just half way that gives us 3
different states down path bent and
raised now we can count using a base 3
positional system up to 59 thousand and
48 and if you can bend your fingers into
4 different states or more you can get
even higher than that limit is up to you
and your own flexibility and ingenuity
even with our fingers in just two
possible States we're already working
pretty efficiently in fact our computers
are based on the same principle each
micro chip consists of tiny electrical
switches that can be either on or off
meaning that base 2 is the default way
they represent numbers and just as we
can use this system to count past 1000
using only our fingers computers can
perform billions of operations just by
counting off ones and zeros
[Music]
you